[Musique]
dans le respect des règles sanitaires le
département souhaité marquer la nouvelle
année 5122 pour les croyants tamouls au
palais de la source
ça s'appelle ils lavent abalo chambre
l'année pile là bas 5122 qu'il faut
c'est une année où il y aura ont pas
beaucoup de l'eau de l'eau de nager de
flotter de couler donc il faut prendre
tous ces thèmes là pour pouvoir
l'utiliser à bon escient le dire de
l'osce a conservé dans toutes les choses
de couler c'est qu'on peut descendre par
unité donc il ya beaucoup de prendre
tout ça pour essayer d'avancer la
période où on est dedans
la collectivité a tenu à rassembler les
représentants des associations tamoules
pour partager les festivités du nouvel
an et faire perdurer les traditions
je j'ai voulu améliorer améliorer tel
dossier afin de pouvoir attirer la
jeunesse lyonnaise
parce qu'enfin compte de plus en plus
que ça se passe cette tradition-là dont
jean originaire de cocotiers fume
beaucoup de choses il faut acheter des
animaux 19 ans compagnies extérieures
basique mais j'ignore jusqu'où présente
c'est une galerie d'image qui
représentent la diversité des supports
mise en ligne sur le site de l'icône
hôtel historique de l'océan indien des
stands de la photographie de la peinture
de l'aquarelle
nous allons voir aussi un deux
diaporamas aujourd'hui un diaporama qui
s'intitule indé qui manque l'un dans
toute sa diversité et un autre diaporama
qui s'intitule à la croisée des chemins
qu'il montre cette histoire des
migrations cette histoire du peuplement
de l'île puisque certains indiens ont
décidé de s'installer à la réunion après
la fin de leur engagement des festivités
qui se sont poursuivies dans l'hémicycle
jusqu'à la commission permanente
[Musique]